pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec hugo dudouit aides
soignants urgences de l'hôpital ambroise
paré membres du collectif inter urgence
bonsoir encore d'être avec nous et hugo
dudouit à ses côtés axel sabban avocat
fiscaliste à paris bonsoir à vous aussi
merci d'être là donc le débat à
l'assemblée un qu'on attendait ça y est
c'est enclenché le gouvernement qui
table toujours sur une adoption en
première lecture avant les élections
municipales dans un mois il se perd même
un feu vert définitif décidé d ça d'ici
l'été ça vous semble possible mettre ça
dans les délais me semble extrêmement
compliqué à tenir quand on voit le
nombre d'amendements qui ont été
déposées en vue de l'examen en séance
donc a tant donné que la commission n'a
pas pu prendre examiné l'intégralité des
amendements qui avaient été déposés par
les députés
ils doivent en principe reprendre
l'examen du texte à 0 évidemment ils
partent d'une des travaux de la
commission
il n'empêche que il ya quarante et un
mille amendements qui ont été déposés
dans le cadre de cet examen en séance
ça me paraît très compliqué de tenir les
délais du gouvernement qui de mémoire
sont fixées au 3 mars pour pour
l'adoption en première lecture
sauf si les députés décident d'avoir des
journées je ne sais pas où ils vont
trouver les heures nécessaires à
l'examen de tous ses amendements et du
texte en général alors je m'adresse à la
fois aux juristes donc le professionnel
du droit mais aussi aux combattants
farouche de cette réforme on va en
parler est ce que vous vous parleriez
d'obstruction parlementaire comme
certains opposants aujourd'hui alors il
ya une volonté d'obstruction
parlementaire qui est assumé par les
députés notamment les députés de la
france insoumise et les députés du parti
communiste mais il faut savoir que cette
volonté d'autres qu'on parte
parlementaire assumer elle se fait en
réaction à ce qu'ils considéraient comme
une obstruction parlementaire mais de la
part du gouvernement
en soumettant d'examen
d'un texte majeur de ce quinquennat
peut-être le texte majeur de ce
quinquennat à des délais de débat aussi
court et surtout à des textes
aujourd'hui qui est qui comporte une
part d'imprécisions qui est très
importante avec une étude d'impact très
volumineuse que les déplier n'ont pas
forcément eu le temps d'en gérer en
intégralité
et tout cela dans un temps extrêmement
court donc obstruction je pense qu'il y
est il est difficile de contester
l'existence d'une obstruction
après savoir si elle est légitime on pas
je garde le jugement là dessus mais en
tout cas c'est ce que le député avance
alors on a du mal à savoir comment ça va
se passer parce que le président de
l'assemblée un richard ferrand proposé
sans succès un gros politique de limiter
à 100 heures sur trois semaines
une réaction est ce que ça va
s'embourber finalement ces débats sans
fin il ya un risque de cela je pense
qu'il risque énorme de toute façon à
vouloir laisser un temps de terminer à
l'examen d'une réforme de cette ampleur
après que ce soit sans heurt 200 plus
non à mon sens une réforme aussi
importante sur la l'organisation de
notre société notre vision de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle
cela mérite d'y consacrer le temps qu'il
faut les députés là dessus doivent à
pouvoir examiner sereinement le texte
s'il décide de son besoin de d'examiner
le texte
jusqu'à cet été ou après il faut leur
laisser le temps nécessaire pour le
faire on va reparler encore avec vous
hugo
dudouit vous vous êtes aide soignant on
l'a dit vous l'avez trouvé comment votre
nouveau ministre celui à qui vous allez
avoir à faire beaucoup ces prochains
temps sur v rente il ya donc lancé
aujourd'hui cette réforme est ce qui
vous a fait plutôt bonne impression
alors je ne sais pas si je peux dire
qu'il a fait bonne impression a tant
donné déjà ce qu'alice musin pu faire
avant on va en parler un évidement tout
à l'heure dans un deuxième temps il a
décidé de lancer une enquête auprès des
soignants pour connaître nos les
difficultés au niveau du travail ça ne
servira à rien parce que ça fait onze
mois qu'on lui rabâche qu'on le crie
haut et fort que ça va pas et c'est pas
qu'une enquête que ça va changer grand
chose aujourd'hui neurologue instable
agnès buzyn était évidemment médecins
spécialistes également c'est un
neurologue qu'est ce que c'est de nature
tout de même à vous rassurer cette
connaissance du terrain du nouveau
ministre est-ce que vous êtes prêts
quand même avant lui elle lui laisser
une chance alors allumé c'est une chance
oui alors après à faire confiance je
sais pas parce qu'alice musée a été
aussi médecin et on voit ce que ça a
donné
et
également médecin en faudra je pense que
ces quelques semaines pour voir ce
qu'ils proposent
on va en parler de toutes façons
effectivement de ce remplacement dans un
deuxième temps ça se passait son pouvoir
qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui sur le dossier
des retraites vous quelle est votre
réaction à vue de nouvelles
manifestations aujourd'hui plutôt
symbolique ces débats qui commencent à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous en
attendez quelque chose vous dans votre
profession
alors moi j'ai 20 ans donc lire la
presse et dans très longtemps encore
vous y pensez quand même au pas ça vous
étonne justement ces grandes
manifestations cette résistance c'est
intéressant de vous poser la question
puisque vous avez 20 ans justement alors
c'est pas que ça m'étonne je pense que
c'est bien c'est bien qu'on se défende
pour tout travailleur ne te sens mieux
après le travail et j'espère contretemps
ça sera évoluer parce que moi je quand
même parti pour être aides soignants ou
infirmer pour l'instant dévolu sur mon
travail - jusqu'à 65 ans donc c'est bien
connu mais est né parce que ces
messieurs se bat et que les jeunes sur
le mouvement aussi ce serait pas mal
alors à l'axel sabban vous avez assisté
à une assemblée générale extraordinaire
au barreau de paris la semaine dernière
vous avez fait vous même différentes
propositions pour essayer vraiment de de
bloquer cette réforme qu'est ce qui en
est ressorti est ce qu'il ya des
propositions qui ont été retenues est ce
que vous allez vous renouveler dans
votre mouvement de contestation ce
projet alors déjà la poursuite de la
grève a été votée par l'assemblée
générale du barreau de paris la première
qui est intervenue depuis 1990 c'est
quand même un fait notable qui démontre
la mobilisation des avocats et la
contestation autour de cette réforme des
retraites le les propositions qui ont
été faites et ça c'est le
le côté que je regrette un peu en fait
intéresse essentiellement une poursuite
de la grève par les avocats plaidants on
reproche beaucoup aux avocats des
cabinets d'ie d'affaires de ne pas
montrer de solidarité à l'égard de la
profession en général
pour ma part j'estime que ce manque de
solidarité ne n'est pas on peut pas dire
qu'on manque de solidarité c'est juste
que des avocats d'affaires n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de d'exercer
leur oeuvre des actions de l'allemagne
de la même manière que les avocats
plaidants c'est exactement pour cela en
fait que je vous propose est une
modalité d'action un peu de nouvelles à
savoir mettre à disposition du barreau
de paris et des barreaux de france un
modèle standard de réclamations
contentieuses permettant à chaque avocat
à chaque citoyen aussi aux avocats
pourraient du coup solliciter leurs
familles leurs proches sujets visant ce
modèle de réclamation permettrait en
fait de contester sur le principe
l'imposition qui a été due au titre des
revenus des années précédentes mais
aussi de la taxe foncière taxe
d'habitation
on peut imaginer tout contester l'idée
l'idée n'est pas forcément d'obtenir des
dégrèvements d'impôts car cela ce modèle
serait standard et il n'aurait pas de
réalité sur le fond en fait ce qui la
proposition visait essentiellement à
demander aux contribuables aux citoyens
de se mobiliser massivement pour saturer
les services de contrôle des
administrations fiscales paralysées les
services de contrôle or les services de
contrôle c'est ce qui permet à l'état
d'assurer le recouvrement en tout cas
d'assurer que le
les impositions sont correctement
recouvrer donc donc en fait attaqué
l'état sur le budget aujourd'hui le
budget c'est quand même le le mot qui
est sur toutes les lèvres au sommet de
l'état il me semblait que attaquer
l'état sur cette question pouvaient
présenter un certain intérêt
surtout que les avocats d'affaires
pouvaient participer de cette manière à
cette contestation contre la réforme des
retraites
alors pour répondre notamment à votre
grogne un celle des avocats les députés
ont voté aussi aujourd'hui en faveur
d'un abattement sur les cotisations des
professions indépendantes est ce que
quand même cette nature un peu à vous
rassurer
non pas du tout alors ça limite l'impact
de la hausse des cotisations serait
avocats les plus les plus précaires
cependant cet abattement ne permet pas
de gommer en intégralité la hausse des
cotisations
or on voit que cette réforme des
retraites elle va impacter
essentiellement les avocats qui se
charge des missions les plus cruciales à
la nôtre à notre justice ce sont les
peines des avocats qui sont en charge de
missions dette juridictionnelle donc il
y exerce des missions à destination des
justiciables les plus fragiles or ces
avocats risquent d'être pénalisés
financièrement par cette réforme des
retraites est ainsi cela pourrait
induire une un nombre d'avocats qui
tombe en liquidation judiciaire par
exemple à bref d un nombre d'avocats
moins important et donc un accès à la
justice plus compliqué pour les
contribuables je pense qu'on a les mêmes
problématiques au niveau de l'hôpital
public en fait c'est fragiliser l'accès
à la justice
donc peut-être dans les zones les plus
tendues ne plus avoir d'avocat pour
permettre de faire valoir ses droits
pour l'hôpital public ne plus avoir de
deux cliniques de maternité de et
obliger les gens à l'hôpital aux
urgences pour sachant qu'un envie c'est
un chiffre 1 40 % de patients qui n'ont
rien à faire aux urgences qui pourrait
très bien consulté un médecin
généraliste
on va en parler justement avec vous on y
vient rester avec nous messieurs olivier
ferrand
vient donc d'être nommé rapporteur il
venait d'être nommé rapporteur du volet
organique de cette réforme des retraites
il prend donc désormais la casquette de
ministre de la santé la passation de
pouvoir s'est déroulée ce matin avec
agnès buzyn ce médecin neurologue
jusque-là député la république en marge
de l'isère occupée depuis deux ans et
demi le poste de rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales
agnès buzyn donc démissionné hier de ses
fonctions pour se lancer dans la
bataille des municipales parisiennes en
remplacement évidemment de l'eau
benjamin griveaux on écoute mesdames et
messieurs c'est avec une grande émotion
que je quitte les histoires et
solidarité va coûter tomber la campagne
des élections municipales à paris
j'ai remis hier soir ma démission au
premier ministre et au président la
république quitter sony ce live on
l'imaginé stade déchirement pendant plus
de deux ans et demi j'ai l'honneur de
conduire des politiques de santé et les
politiques sociales de notre pays
voilà godet lui je me tourne maintenant
vraiment vers vous agnès buzyn très ému
qui dit au revoir un ministère déjà
votre réaction
j'imagine que vous avez beaucoup
échanger avec vous vos collègues c'est
un regret ce un soulagement ça laisse la
porte ouverte là peut-être de nouvelles
espérances pour vous alors en premier
lieu c'est un dégoût moi personnellement
j'ai re après onze mois de mobilisation
elle quitte le bateau winmo pour le
moment la crise et hôpitaux la craie des
urgences le coronavirus c'est une crise
sanitaire dont qu'elle abandonne ses
dossiers au profit d' une campagne
municipale ont compris fille est
certainement d'un plan personnel alors
on peut pas les juger en soit c
et pas elle qui a décidé de directement
démissionner on est à l'émotion on peut
se poser effectivement la question
est-ce qu'elle a choisie ou en tout cas
on lui a proposé fortement en tous cas
pour vous c'est clairement un abandon de
poste avec des dossiers qui sont très
lourd et très important évidemment pour
vous et pour le pays c'est ça parce que
l'association hôpital public à elle va
mal ça fait deux mois qu'on le dise même
des années que c'est dit et l'arrivée du
nouveau ministre a pas je pense changer
grand chose à la situation
après trois cent mille signatures d'une
pétition mais manifestations répétées et
plein d'autres types d'actions on est
toujours au point zéro
on n'avance pas pour vous est-ce qu'il
ya un bilan qui est totalement négative
de la part de la ministre
buzeins où il y a quand même eu des
choses à son crédit totalement négatif
sur moi qui ai je ne suis plus deux ans
je n'ai rien vu de positif en deux ans
on m'a vendu du rêve quand j'ai commencé
à travailler c'est du rêve parce qu'il
ya du travail de l'équipe c'est très
beau c'est le citoyen c'est un des plus
beaux métiers du monde
mais au niveau de tout ce qui est autour
c'est très moche
j'empoigne est justement le terme de
soulagement parce que j'ai anticipé
cette réponse rien de positif pour vous
on peut comprendre qu' il y ait
effectivement on peut-être le sentiment
d'être méprisés quand un ministre pas
sur un gros dossier mais est ce que
justement vous n'avez pas l'espoir que
ça ouvre la porte
peut-être à d'autres propositions avec
olivier ferrand alors je pense un léger
soulagement quand même avec un petit un
flan vent nouveau faudra voir dans les
semaines à venir ce qui me proposera 100
quel plan et va se baser ou ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on va pas lui et c'est le
cadeau qu'ils ont ça fait trop longtemps
qu'on attendait revendications coup et
et nos revendications soient entendues
et il a commencé par dire qu'il est et
qui n'auraient pas tour de chauffe qu'il
était connaissez les dossiers qu'ils
étaient prêts à partir alors on l'attend
on va voir je peux comprendre votre
votre colère face à au départ d'agnès b
en fait on est confronté aujourd'hui
enfin le ministère de la santé est
confronté quand même une triple crise
donc la crise sociétale avec la réforme
des retraites la crise institutionnelle
la crise de l'hôpital et une crise
sanitaire avec le coronavirus on a une
ministre qui part faire des municipales
à paris donc qui n'est absolument pas
préparé pour cet enjeu des municipales
mais quel message que cela envoie au
fond c'est qu'un ministre peut être
parfaitement remplacé sur des sujets
extrêmement technique qui soulève
énormément de grogne parmi nos citoyens
mais en fait est-ce que ce ministre là
est vraiment porteur d'un message
personnel d'une d'une touche personnelle
sur les réformes
ou alors c'est juste un produit
politique qui remplaçables à volonté car
de toute façon les orientations
techniques sont décidés autres parents
on peut se poser la question de la
pertinence de l'identité du ministre de
la santé en fait aujourd'hui si on peut
remplacer n'importe quelle politique
d'un claquement de doigts c'est beaucoup
trop facile et ça permet de justifier
largement la colère de personnes qui
sont placés sous la tutelle de ce
ministère et goodwill risquent d'être
racing émissaires du gouvernement
si jamais elle rate aux municipales on
dira que marla c'était toute sa faute
merci en tout cas à tous les deux axel
sabban urgo déduit d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous dans quelques uns